the cost in dollars of producing X
gallons of wood stain is given by C of X
is equal to 3,200 plus 0.1 X minus 0.001
x squared plus zero point zero zero zero
for X to the third power what is a
formula for the marginal cost function C
prime of X so we really just have to
take the derivative of C with respect to
X to think about how does C change as X
changes as our quantity increases how
does our cost change so what's the
derivative of this right over here well
the derivative of 3,200 with respect to
X is just zero the derivative of 0.1 X
is 0.1 the derivative of negative 0.001
x squared is going to be negative zero
point zero zero two X and then finally
the derivative of this is going to be
let's see this is for 10,000 so three
times four ten thousands is twelve ten
thousands so zero point one two three
four I up this 12 ten thousandth x
squared so that right over there is
equal to the marginal cost function so
if you see this had an exercise you just
want to type in the expression here but
this of course is equal to this of
course is equal to C prime of X to the
nearest to the nearest penny what is the
marginal cost of producing the hundred
first one hundred first gallon of stain
so they say C prime of a hundred is
equal to blank dollars per gallon so
what are they wanting is what do they
want us to do here well they really want
us to do is approximate what the
incremental cost of the next gallon is
going to be using the marginal cost
function so for example let's say let's
say that this right over here so this is
the number of this is our x-axis this is
a hundred gallons and let's say this is
the next gallon as 101 gallons and our
cost function might look something like
this
so our cost function might look
something like this when you calculate C
prime of 100 so C prime of 100 is going
to give you is going to give you the
slope at this point it's going to give
you this the slope the slope of the
tangent line at this point that's C
prime of 100 so let me write this slope
is equal to C prime of 100 and so what
they really want us to figure out if we
want to know the exact actual cost of
producing 101st gallon what we would do
is we'd say well look this value right
over here is C of 100 this value up here
this value R over here is C of C of 101
we've done in a different color C of 1 C
of 101 if you if you just want to
calculate the exact cost of producing
that next extra unit you would take C of
101 minus C of 100 and so that's what
they want us to do next to do the exact
cost but we can approximate it using the
marginal the marginal cost the
derivative of our cost function right at
this point we can figure out what this
slope is C prime of 100 and then
multiply it times that one extra unit
multiply it times that one extra unit if
you take a slope and you multiply it
times remember slope is change in Y or
change in the vertical axis over the
change in the horizontal axis if you
then multiply it times a change in the
horizontal axis which in this case is
one unit it's going to give you the
resulting change in the vertical axis so
in this first one if you take C prime of
100 and then multiply that times one
unit so you're still just going to get C
prime of 100 you're going to get this
distance right over here you're going to
get this distance right over here which
we can view as an approximation for this
large one I exaggerated the difference
between this curve and this tangent line
but let's just actually calculate it and
I'll get my calculator out to do it so C
prime of 100 is going to be C prime of
100 is C prime so it's 0.1 minus point
zero zero two times 100
times 100 plus point zero zero 1 2 times
100 squared which is going to be 10,000
volts type that in so it's $11.90
so this is going to be 11 90 1190 so
that's this right over here we just took
this slope times 1 we're doing one extra
gallon and we're getting this
approximation which is this distance
being 11 dollars 98 the thing right over
here and see let's see we could actually
simplify it a little bit before I even
type it into my calculator this
expression is going to be 32 hundred
thirty-two hundred plus 0.1 times 101
minus 0.001 times 101 on the switch
colors for contrast times 101 squared
plus zero point zero zero zero four
times 101 to the third power and then
we're going to subtract 3,200 we're
going to subtract zero point one times
100 we're going to then add zero point
two zero zero one times 100 squared and
then we're going to subtract let me to
change colors here subtract zero point
zero zero zero four times 100 to the
third 100 to the third power so let's
get the calculator out and calculate
that so 3,200 s will cancel out so I
don't have to type even type that in and
let's see this is going to be we could
write this as 0.1 times 101 minus 100
well that's just going to be one I don't
have to do that so it's going to be
these two are going to cut this is just
going to be 0.1 so then we're going to
have minus minus 0.001 times 101 squared
101 squared minus 100 squared minus 100
squared and then we have plus plus 0z
point zero zero zero four times 101 to
the third power minus 100 to the third
power minus 100 to the third power gives
us 12 they sit to the nearest penny so
twelve dollars and two cents so this is
going to be twelve dollars and two cents
so that was a pretty good approximation
using the derivative and multiplying by
the number of that incremental number of
units that was a pretty good
approximation for the actual difference
which was the actual cost of producing
that next unit was twelve dollars and
two cents and you might say once again
why is a discrepancy remember the
marginal cost is derivative is just for
the next very the next drop right at
that instance the instantaneous rate of
change well each drop was getting each
incremental drop is getting more and
more and more expensive because the
curve does not have a constant slope
does not have a constant rate of change
so we use this as you can view this as
really a linear approximation and this
of this right over here is the exact
value